leute ich hatte heute nacht einen traum
ein traum was nicht nicht so ein traum
anton und zwar leute ich habe jetzt noch
keine tattoos aber jetzt schon darüber
nachgedacht mich tätowieren zu lassen
jetzt ist das ein bisschen aufgetaucht
bitte nicht warum aber ich habe geträumt
dass ich mir hier jetzt geträumt ich
habe mir hier auf den oberarm
fitness first
das hat mein interesse für diese ganze
thema tattoos wieder bisschen gesteigert
deswegen ziehen uns heute die
schlechtesten tattoos aller zeiten einig
wer darauf reagieren ich will
gleichzeitig informationen für mich
sammeln weil ich jetzt quasi auf der
suche nach dem richtigen motiv und so
ernst ich glaube es hat viel dabei sein
was mir die lust nicht hätte werden zu
lassen
du wirst noch nicht immer ist okay aber
das erste ass text der hund ist das
einzigste wesen der hund ist das
einzigste wesen auf der erde dass ich
mehr liebt wie sich selbst wie viele
rechtschreibfehler kann man in diesen
satz frei machen ganz davon abgesehen
dass das ist der richtig geschrieben das
alles ist hier der hund blieb den
menschen mehr hat sich selbst der himmel
ist blau
alter schwede und dann noch achtung
einzigste das gibt's nicht dann das
schaut mal mit einem ass und mehr liebt
als sich selbst wenn wir irgendwelche
asiatischen schriftzeichen stechen lässt
uns übersetzt truthahn sandwich bedeuten
ist das dein ernst ist das scheißegal
was denken sie denn die menschen derweil
leute nach vier wochen sagt überlegung
und lange auseinandersetzung mit dem
thema möchte jetzt gerne tut hat wird
auf den artikeln lassen komme zum
dritten bild
kannst du weitermachen manchmal ist man
die sache ist das schlimmste daran ist
leute das ist hier nicht nur die
personen die sich tätowieren lässt
sondern auch die das tattoo macht beide
sind in diesem prozess drin und beide
denken sich na klar wer sich tätowieren
lassen dass ihre mutter ihr winkel ist
angel cappa englisch enge und engel also
maicosuel vertauscht und erst dann ist
ihr kommt heißt dass winkel sowie ein
geodreieck mal das das was du sagen
wollten ein paar leute ich versuche ich
wirklich eine vielseitige reaktion zu
bieten aber jede meisten von diesen
bildern will ich einfach aus diesem raum
rauslaufen und einfach dieses kapitel
hinterlassen
neben der leistung in deutschland gut an
der stelle muss man auch sagen ist
natürlich auch ein relativ kleines
tattoo hat nur circa einer breite von 60
cm
die buchstaben sind wahrscheinlich ca 15
zentimeter groß da kann man in
deutschland durchaus schon mal das l
vergessen
klar wenn ich dich dann weil die
tätowier davor so er macht das so und
schreibt und schreibt beschreibt
mannschaft deutschland2011 also quasi
pages schmerz und games zuwachs also
verbesserung das heißt wenn du kannst
keinen schmerz hast kannst du dich auch
nicht verbessern der ja dass ein
bisschen interpretiert in le pen
okay okay leute weiter text sich wieder
beruhigen niemand ich habe einen kaffee
getrunken beruhigt habe ich mich jetzt
nicht heute jeder von uns kommt in
seinem leben an einen punkt wo er sie
fragt was
echte sinn von dem was ich mache wieso
stehe ich jeden tag auf es gibt menschen
auf der welt es gibt einzigartige köpfe
die in ihrer mentalen fähigkeiten so
weit vorne sind dass sie für die welt
gründe entwickeln und motive entwickeln
mit dem man sein leben leben kann oder
eines dieser super hier haben wir auf
diesem bild abgebildet leute und sein
leitspruch den er entwickelt hat um die
menschheit voran zu bringen ist miley
ist game
denkt mal darüber nach was könnte das
bedeuten mileys game merkt ja auch für
die erleuchtung durch durch strömt
beruhigt euch kommt runter und dann
denkt man darüber nach
mein leben ist spiel und das nächste
bedeute stand aus dieser selben
kategorie aus der kategorie dinge und
wörter die die menschheit voran treiben
dieser spruch rapper don't give up die
sache ist sollte ich glaube jetzt müssen
zu gut gemeint würde mal sagen never
give up also es gibt mir auch würde man
sagen don't give up heißt es gibt nicht
auf aber never don't give up heißt in
der kommen jetzt natürlich gibt nicht
auf also gibt immer auch hierzu nun mal
so wenn du morgens versucht aus dem bett
aufzustehen gebe einfach auf bleibt
liegen wenn du versucht ein schluck
wasser aus der flasche zu trinken gibt
einfach auf
also ich kann sagen das motto hat für
mich jetzt schon super funktioniert ich
bin einfach viel besser drauf als vorher
leute ihr könnt jetzt wollen in die
kommentare einstellen ob ihr denkt das
zu mir ein tattoo passen würde macht das
wirklich meine wirklich interessieren
und dann könnt ihr selbstverständlich
leute auch hier in der folge was das gen
abdecken
einfach hier auf meinem finger oben
drüber